in ukraine overnight russia fired more
missiles at the port city of odessa far
beyond the front lines you are looking
now at a shopping mall that was hit
multiple times officials say at least
one person was killed there and several
others were wounded deborah pat is in
ukraine where the reality of the war is
far from what the kremlin is telling the
russian people
russia's distorted reality a jubilant
end to victory day lights up the night
skies above moscow but in ukraine russia
really has nothing to celebrate vladimir
putin's war is failing says acting u.s
ambassador christina kavin it would be
hard to find something that he could
claim victory for frankly
i haven't seen any clear victories at
all in this war so far for president
putin
but he has caused untold misery across
the east and south of the country
in the port city of odessa the jagged
remains of a shopping mall ripped apart
and in the eastern village of seversk
ash's still smolder
it's hard to imagine anything could
survive this nightmare
this elderly woman has endured heavy
shelling she lies flat on her bed to
escape the bombing
my son is dead she weeps i have no one
to protect me
russia is locked in a modern day david
and goliath battle and for all its heavy
artillery it has suffered heavy losses
up north ukrainian forces are pushing
russian troops back from harkeev just
like they did in kiev back in april and
now people are slowly coming back to the
capital
i just came into my house for the first
time today it was a little emotional it
was really special to be back i'm so so
happy to be here
to see all of my old friends
she's not alone amidst all the pain
occasional moments of joy like this
mother who was reunited with her son
after 74 days separated by war
for cbs mornings deborah patter kiev
ukraine